So Donald Trump first got his worst polling
during this campaign so far down to Joe Biden
by 14 points nationally.
And these are just unconscionable numbers.
And a report from Axios about what's going
on inside the Trump White House and inside
the Trump campaign shows panic, fear, anger
at what's going on.
So this latest poll from CNN and CNN is rated
as a B plus pollster by 538.
Their polling is pretty good.
They have Trump's approval down to 38 percent.
That rivals the lows of Trump's presidency.
And then in terms of Biden versus Trump for
November, this poll has Biden at 55.
Trump at forty one.
Now, what's important about this poll, other
than Biden's absolutely ridiculous 14 point
lead, is that Biden is well above 50 percent.
If you look back to June of 2016, in other
words, this time in the 2016 election, Hillary
Clinton was very rarely hitting 50 percent.
You can go back and you can find a poll here
or there
where Hillary had 50, maybe 51.
But in June of 2016, Hillary Clinton was mostly
polling in the low 40s and occasionally in
the high 40s with the occasional 50 or 51.
Joe Biden is now regularly polling at 50 percent
or more in recent polls.
And that is a very different starting point
than where Hillary Clinton was back in June
of 2016.
Now, the difference is Biden is running against
an incumbent, whereas Hillary Clinton running
against Trump was two challengers or two potential
candidates.
And there is some degree to which one might
expect as we get closer to the election, people
will break for the incumbent, and that would
certainly benefit Donald Trump.
So publicly, Trump is insisting that he's
doing really well.
He very often will tweet versions of what
he tweeted this morning, this morning, saying,
quote, 96 percent approval rating in the Republican
Party.
Thank you.
The sources never cited the source is never
clear, but Trump posts that all the time.
And publicly he's pretending that he's doing
really well and that Joe Biden can't win unless
Democrats cheat in the fall or something like
that, which is hilarious.
By the way, privately, Donald Trump's aides
and advisers are coming to him and telling
him these polls don't look good and you need
to do something.
They know how bad the polls are.
A source briefed on internal polls is calling
them, quote, brutal and seeing a major drop
off in independent support.
While Trump's Republican support is remaining
relatively high, his Democratic support is
extremely low.
Independents have been shifting away from
Trump significantly in the last few months.
The when the looting starts, the shooting
starts thing that Trump said is troubling
for some of Donald Trump's top aides.
And
clearly, they know that Trump's disgustingly
divisive reaction to the protests have hurt
them.
And they are saying Trump needs to instead
give a message of hope, optimism and unification.
And from that recommendation came this idea
that's now being floated about maybe Trump
could give a, quote, major speech on race.
Now, I have to tell you, as hilarious as a
major speech on race would be from Donald
Trump, I don't even know that I would cover
it.
Normally, I would stream major presidential
speeches, but I don't know that I would cover
that.
It would be merely a propaganda piece.
Trump probably would barely even understand
what he was reading off of his prompter.
It would be calculated to try to get a few
more points in a poll.
And I don't even know that I would cover that
speech.
Now a few insights into a Zoome
call that took place with Trump's top campaign
advisers, Corey Lewandowski.
Ask the question, what is our message?
Which is a relevant question.
It's not clear what Trump's message is right
now.
They seem to settle on the idea of something
like a great American comeback theme.
The idea of using those misreported jobs numbers
from last week to build this optimistic comeback
strategy for the next five months, that's
going to be tough because Donald Trump, on
one hand, is appealing to his hardcore base
with his wild and hateful and divisive rhetoric,
talking about sending in the military ominous
weapons.
That doesn't play well with a lot of people.
But if Trump switches to a unification message
to try to get his polling up, it's not clear
that that's going to play well with his hard
core supporters.
What would be nice would be for Trump to say,
hey, you know what, guys?
We failed.
The country has lost confidence in me.
If they ever had it, we are all going to be
resigning.
We failed.
We are failures.
And I'm sorry.
That's what should happen.
It will never happen.
They are going to have.
Be removed when you get a tick in, it attaches
to your body and you try to just pull it off.
You can't.
The tick hangs on for dear life.
They are going to have to be removed like
a deer tick.
You're going to have to pour alcohol on it.
Take tweezers.
Squeeze it by the head and try to get it to
release its grip on your skin.
That's the analogy of how they're going to
have to be removed.
These are some of Trump's best, worst numbers
ever.
But at the same time, 38 percent of the country
thinks he's doing a good job.
That is horrifying.
And it means he can win in November.
And I don't know if the 38 percent are people
who are cultlike in their following of Trump
or what he does doesn't matter or they're
not paying attention or they don't care or
they're cognitively impaired.
I don't know what it is.
But he still has 38 percent support.
He can still win.
And we need to get out there and make sure
that we prevent the reelection in November.